We have a voicemail number
that you can call anytime.
That number is two one nine two. David
P.. I continue to hear from folks who are
not as convinced as I am that a split in
the Republican Party and a Trump party
would be good for the left. Here's a
caller asking about exactly that issue.
David, a student from Wisconsin. So I just watched
your segment regarding the Republican Party and.
Sixty four percent possibly leaving for some
party. Right. And I don't mean this is a good
thing for the Dem party because it would split
up the votes of the Republican Party. But I don't
know if that's the case. I think that it may be
the case that it's good for the Democratic Party,
although I think that this Trump
party may be a problem from the
standpoint of violence. I mean, can you.
OK, so I think they said, can you imagine using
one of my my phrases there, as I said earlier
today? In the fight between neocon and Kuhnen,
which is essentially what Republicans versus
Trumpet's would be if Kuhnen gets big and becomes
dominant on the right, I completely agree that
there is a very real risk of increased violence
in the United States, as evidenced by the January
6th riots. That's a different question as to what
it means politically for the left in the
Democratic Party. I think without question,
if the right is fractured, listen, it's
already borderline. The right already lost
the White House and the Senate in 2020, the way
that they are currently sort of assembled. So
I think that already the ability of the Republican
Party without some modifications to win national
elections is really in question. If you fracture
it at all, it is good for the Democratic Party
if they are actually set up and ready to take
advantage of it. There is no question that there
is a whole other set of considerations. And if
you see the kuhnen wing of the Republican Party
grow and become further weaponized, even against
other Republicans that they see as traitors,
it could be extraordinarily dangerous for
this country. And it will keep the hate
group watchers very, very busy for long periods of
time to come. So I don't disagree with the call.
I just think the political considerations
are different. Once we have a great Bonas
show for you today, we will talk about Joe
Biden extending protections for homeowners.
Very interesting set of
changes that is being made.
We will also talk about a warning that a January
6th commission to investigate the Trump riots
may be quite difficult politically.
We'll talk about why. And the Texas
mayor has resigned after calling power
outage victims lazy, at least the guys
taking personal responsibility. Right. All of
those stories and more on today's bonus show.
Get instant access by becoming a member
at Join Pakman Dotcom. I'll see you then.